well welcome back to Facebook and
uncensored and historic moment in
American history Donald Trump has
pleaded not guilty to all counts and
called in Miami facing 37 criminal
charges over his handling of classified
documents he's the first current or
former president to ever face federal
charges commentator and author Megan
McCain joins me now while Megan I just
had a very robust defense of Donald
Trump from Carrie Lake uh yeah I can't
imagine you've shared to say I think
you're like No And I think you're one of
like the most even killed journalists at
work thank you I didn't understand thank
you antagonistic that's when she says
outrageous but Megan great to have you
on the show I was like you were
literally fired for free speech thank
you anyway thank you to be here as well
it's great to have you it's a pleasure
to be here as well what is your what is
your reaction to this really quite
historic moment I mean this is the first
time any American president oryx has
ever been charged with federal charges
this is a big moment
oh it's huge I mean it will be something
that my children will read about in
history books and it's you know it's
it's really disheartening it's really
depressing as an American it's
embarrassing I mean the global culture
is watching us and you know seeing
what's happening he's the by far the
front runner as you saw with your last
guest there are people that will vote
for him if he is you know sent to prison
and would be running the country from
prison so it's amazing to me that um you
know he's he's accused of 37 counts it's
a lot uh you know General Petraeus
almost went to jail for three so I I
think we're in a situation that is
obviously unprecedented and
um you know unusual Waters but that's no
different than anything we've dealt with
with President Trump I'm interested to
see how the current group of people
running for president on the Republican
ticket are going to be handling it going
forward because right now a lot of them
are defending him right I mean that's
the really interesting question isn't it
because at some point the Republican
party has to make a decision about
whether it can actually go forward with
a guy who facing not just State charges
over hush payments to a porn star but is
now facing 37 incredibly serious charges
on this indictment you know about under
the Espionage Act about basically using
classified documents or into nuclear
power to you know to how you would go
after enemy States and so on this is not
chicken feed this is serious stuff
no and look I woke up this morning to
the news that I read online that um
there was a person who had gone to the
White House and appeared topless at a
pride party over the weekend and I was
just saddened and also horrified at the
state of different kinds of things going
on in the country uh Joe Biden is
incredibly weak candidate 75 percent of
independent candidates voters don't want
him running for president uh 80 percent
of Republicans over 50 percent of
Democrats don't want him running for
president Republicans can literally only
lose this election if we nominate Donald
Trump and it looks like that's what
we're doing and I think we're going to
have to have a really hard look as as to
what our party but also what our country
is going to look look like with him
being the front runner that being said I
don't see a lot of Courage coming out of
Washington D.C and courage coming out of
these candidates running there's no one
I'm particularly excited about including
Ron DeSantis and none of this is good
enough and I think part of it is if you
walk this line where you're going to you
know suck up to president Trump and want
to get his supporters but at the same
time I want to you know differentiate
yourself from him it's not something
that's going to be possible and I do
think there is a lot of voter fatigue
and those 75 percent of independent
voters are going to make or break this
election and if there's one thing we've
learned they do not like President Trump
I mean look this whole debate around
Trump has got so toxic so tribal you
know I've had times when I've supported
Trump and I've had times not least when
he attacked your great father when I
felt his behavior has been completely
sickening uh and demeaning of anyone
who's ever held the office of President
so Trump is this kind of character where
you can like him for some things and to
test him for others but he's got this
extraordinary Stranglehold over a large
number of Republican voters and if
you're going to try and beat him for the
nomination you've got to somehow as
you've just rather well articulated
you've got to somehow bring those people
with you without trashing their hero
it's difficult
yeah and your last guest um you know not
to make it too personal but she went
down that road and told anyone who voted
for McCain to get the hell out and
that's exactly what happened to her she
is not the governor of Arizona no matter
what she thinks in her brain and the
exact same thing will happen to
president Trump he has lost Arizona a
very valuable swing state this will come
down to three swing state states in the
United States of America as it always
does and president Trump has lost all
three the last two election Cycles so
I'm not exactly sure why we continue to
put our cart next to this losing horse
especially given as you said the
historic circumstances today but you
know I'm I'm 38 I'm a different
generation I'm a different voter
demographic and there just seems to be a
lot of quite frankly older Boomers that
have a Stranglehold on the party and
want to see President Biden get
reelected and I for one don't want an 86
year old to be president uh leaving
office in the next cycle I think that's
a very dangerous precedent for our
country and my understanding is I work
at a UK publication at a job you used to
have at the daily feel that a lot of our
friends across the pond think it's quite
bizarre that we have a president that's
this old and would be that old if
re-elected well he could have a choice
at the 2024 election if things go the
way people fear well you have a man who
appears to be senile against someone who
might actually have been convicted of
federal offenses under the Espionage Act
I mean it's a completely extraordinary
situation
yeah and I think it's why a lot of
people are looking at RFK Jr I'm not a
fan of his nor a supporter but he has
upwards of 20 percent of democrat
support right now independent support
coming strong and I don't think it's
that he's a particularly interesting
candidate or politician uh you know I
think he's an activist married to a
famous actress but I think it's just
that people are just so thirsty for
anything that's different than these two
candidates and just from a you know
holistic standpoint for the American
people this is a very depressing very
scary time to have these two men as the
most powerful men leading both parties
and I think it's a recipe for disaster
and I quite frankly think it's a recipe
for even more disenfranchisement of what
people call the establishment what
people call uh you know as Curie Lake
was saying like people in media circles
and establishment media I don't adhere
to that line of thinking but it does
make you very cynical about who's
running things and I think an example of
that is the Democratic National
Committee is not allowing President
Biden to do any debates I think the
American public deserves to watch him
debate to any of the candidates who are
running for president and like I said
RFK Jr has over 20 percent Marianne
Williamson has 10 these are not numbers
that any Democrat strategist should be
ignoring right now yeah I completely
agree uh Megan always read your columns
in the Daily Mail they're the second
best columns the males ever run
obviously
you always provoke thought and that's
the best thing about being a good
columnist so thank you very much Steve
for joining me I appreciate it
foreign
thank you
so what does this all mean for the
future of the Republican Party in the
2024 presidential race okay live
pictures here of a courtroom in Miami
where the recently deposed president
Trump has just been charged on 37 counts
37 involving classified documents of the
most top secret stuff involving
America's apparently evolving America's
nuclear program uh its plans for
potentially attacking enemy States and
so on very sensitive stuff that he
shouldn't have had in the first place
and then when he was asked to hand it
back according to the indictment he
didn't had a lot of it back
um so these are serious things and you
can explain away Trump defend him as
much as you want feel like you know he's
getting a hard time the indictment is
serious when you read it joining me now
is the conservative radio host Ben
Ferguson the host of the Reuben report
Dave Rubin all right guys uh there's a
battle raging here now for the soul of
the Republican party and a real quandary
what does the Republican Party do about
this growing number of legal issues that
Donald Trump is facing Ben Ferguson yeah
where are we here Donald Trump all right
yeah the storm be Daniel stuff you can
sort of joke that away say it's trivial
bit of a Witch Hunt stupid I don't
disagree with that particularly but this
stuff when I read the indictment is very
serious if this was Joe Biden and it was
leveled at him or Obama you would be
leading the charge probably to have him
executed
not executed but I would be leading the
charge uh for classified documents if
you're going to have this level of
accountability for a republican then
then damn it you better do it for
everybody on the left that has also done
this and there was no accountability and
this is going to be why this is not a
big issue in the primary for Donald
Trump there was their accountability for
Hillary Clinton the three thousand
thirty thousand plus emails literally
telling her staff to take hammers to
blackberries and cell phones zero
accountability and that's going to be
the talking point for Donald Trump I
think he actually gets closer to the
nomination uh today with this indictment
because there are so many Americans
conservatives that are sick and tired of
a two-tier justice system where this
system goes after Republicans and looks
the other way when there's meetings on
tarmacs uh between former President Bill
Clinton uh and the Attorney General
talking about Hillary Clinton they've
had enough of it now does that mean that
this is going to be a good thing for the
Republicans and the Gen General I think
it's way too soon to tell peers But
ultimately right now there's a lot of
pissed off Americans that are sick and
tired of this two justice system here
and there's a lot of examples of it for
goodness sakes look at the day they
charged him you've got Intel that
apparently five million dollars went
from one of the executives at barisma in
a bribery scheme to the sitting
president United States of America and
the majority of the mainstream media was
silent on it so okay are people shocked
by this no they're not they're angry
over it let me bring in Dave though
because the issue to me is there's also
a political element to this and if I'm a
republican this rapidly coming a point
when you have clear options I mean you
could have Ron DeSantis I went down to
Florida interview I thought it was
pretty impressive he's a genuine
conservative he's been wildly successful
in Florida turning a 33 000 majority
into one and a half million he's Trump
without the baggage he's very trumpian
in all of his policies you know Trump's
tried to rubbish him and rubbish what
he's achieved he's obviously in my
estimation be nonsense that charge why
would the Republicans want to pursue the
Trump Road to nomination when it's so
fraught with potential danger and when
he might be the only person that could
actually let Joe Biden win
well the short answer to that is that
Trump does have a certain captivation
over the world in the last you know
decade or so that allows people to
follow him whether things are working or
not working look at the moment I agree
with you and with Ben on this idea that
the the thing that people are most upset
by at the moment is the selective
prosecution and persecution of Donald
Trump when they see the asymmetry that
Biden and Hillary and and even Mike
Pence says VP can get away with
classified document things and Donald
Trump can't that asymmetry is what
bothers people but on the DeSantis front
I I completely agree with you peers we
have what I think and you know I I moved
to Florida during covid in large part
because of Ron DeSantis and moved my
family here in two companies here and I
have a ton of flourishing people that
I'm around now in a state that is
functioning I would say really at the
Pinnacle of the world for Freedom right
now uh we have a guy who has done
everything he has set out to do in his
legislative agenda he has fought the
woke he has got the neo-racism out of
the schools he's gotten the gender stuff
out in effect he beat Disney he's doing
all of the things that anyone who is
conservative minded or or right-leaning
or roughly Republican or even a
disaffected liberal which there's a lot
of people I think you're probably a
little bit in that category uh I think
he's the guy that can get everybody out
of this but but that's sort of a
separate issue than what the base of the
base the carry Lake types who I like how
she's on one hand calling you a sellout
and then also saying God bless you I
love talking to you uh that they're
never they're Never Gonna Leave the
they're Never Gonna Leave the Trump
orbit but I think there Ron DeSantis
offers a chance for a whole bunch of new
people to come into the fold Trump I
just don't see where the new people are
even putting aside all of the
indictments and the craziness where are
the new Trump voters that's a good
question yeah let me bring Ben back on
that I mean the real issue is who can
win the independence for example yeah I
just don't see Independence exactly
liking any of the they're all dedicated
this aghast and I don't disagree with
you by the way there are legitimate
allegations of double standards in the
way that Hillary's emails and Joe
Biden's documents and so on have been
treated by the liberal skewed mainstream
media I completely agree with that but
purely on Trump and what he's done here
and what we apparently are going to hear
from his own voice on a tape where he
concedes these are not Declassified
documents contrary to everything he's
been saying this is a real sort of
Damocles hanging over the party and you
could end up with the most damaged
candidate in history and that might be
the only way Biden notwithstanding all
his issues ends up winning so why is the
Smart play for the Republicans not to go
for a much safer option of yeah it's a
great question look I like Rhonda Santos
I I said this I don't want a Civil War
the night after Rhonda centers announced
and I said if you took Donald Trump's
name and referred to him as candidate a
and you took the Sandra's name off a
page and said can it be both of those
candidates the Republican Party would be
jumping up and down and screaming over
the difference though appears as this
there's a big asterisk now next to any
accusations against Donald Trump and the
reason why many Americans than in this
especially in this primary and going
into the general are saying we don't
believe you when you tell us that Donald
Trump's a bad person you said he was
colluding with the Russians we now know
that the Deep State lied to us the top
FBI and CIA directors were lying to us
and they signed that letter also saying
the hunter Biden laptop was not real not
authentic and it was had the markings of
the Russian government
again
I know the line you're taking on this
and I don't disagree with you I thought
the Russian collusion thing was a load
of trump top nonsense no pun intended I
thought the way that the uh Hunter Biden
laptop thing was suppressed uh by big
Tech was outrageous
um but ultimately this we are where we
are and I still I still believe I still
believe that the Trump route to victory
for the Republicans in 2024 is fraught
with danger
um
he's gonna make is he's going to say Do
you believe me or believe them because
I get that and there are lots of people
lots of Mega supporters that will
believe him David final question for you
um
who is going to win the nomination give
me a name
I really think Ron DeSantis is going to
win the nomination I think the polls are
closing I think the more people get to
see him get to see the competence the
clarity his ability to communicate the
right ideas see his track record he's 44
years old he's younger than me he's got
three young kids fantastic wife in the
first lady of Florida Casey DeSantis I
think he's got the right message without
the baggage and I think as time goes on
I think you're right Pierce people are
getting tired of this that is not an
excuse related to The Selective
persecution of trump but people everyone
has a limit to how much they can take
and I'm hearing from an awful lot of
people when I travel the country they're
like we thank Trump we appreciate Trump
he woke us up he red pilled us but that
doesn't mean he has to be king forever
[Music]
guys I'm gonna leave her there but it
reminds me very much of our situation
with Boris Johnson in this country look
at the donations does Santa's got a lot
of money coming in follow that as well
because there's a lot of people out
there writing him big checks right now
and people said oh he's dead in the
water I don't think he is at all
honestly the debates also I would look
at the scores on the board as DeSantis
told me when I interviewed him I'm a
school's on the board guy and he wins
and Trump in the last few years has been
a perennial loser